it's time for our seen and unseen
segment where we expose the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to Fox News contributor Raymond aroyo
all right Raymond it was a bizarre day
on Capitol Hill it was lur look I think
Hunter Biden's stunt appearance brought
out the worst in everybody after
refusing to comply with those two
subpoenas he suddenly showed up and
there was chaos in the chamber then it
was like every member of the House had
binge watched Hunter Biden's laptop
suddenly they were all porn graphic
speaking pornography NIH really should
send some soap up there for their
mouths you are the epitome of white
privilege ignoring a congressional
subpoena to be deposed what are you
afraid of you have no balls she is a
person that showed nude photos of Hunter
Biden In This Very committee room
showing showing piics in this committee
room uh of of Hunter Biden let's talk
about the fact that President Trump Inc
Ed an erection and maybe that
too Laura these are some dirty-minded
people that's all I can say really Ian
they can't help themselves I mean I I I
I don't know to me the whole thing was
just but look it's all they have the the
Administration has stunts everything's
white supremacist you know Donald
Trump's against Dem I no no election
will ever be held again if Donald Trump
wins it's all they have is stunts but
you know with all due respect to
chairman he should have when he saw
Hunter come into the the committee room
he should have had the capital police
seal the doors they should have sworn in
the witness and they should have grilled
him about why he has denied these two
subpoena requests he he he to let him
come in and leave that that stunt should
never have happened but Laur Hunter
fever seemed to spread even to reporters
as Hunter Biden left the hearing room
one reporter did his best to crack the
story or get the story on crack what
kind of crack do you normally smoke Mr
Biden let me start again hun Biden was
and is a private citizen this
Republicans have sought to use him as a
to attack his father hun what's your
favorite type
of are
you well chasing down the big stories
that's all I can say I didn't well well
it is kind of a circus now there's a new
report on his art sales Raymond which
we've been fascinated by great works of
art house investigators have uncovered
that the majority of the purchases were
made by shocker Democratic donors well
but George Burgess the Hunter's art
dealer told the investigators in the
house that the majority of the art sales
$875,000 worth came from one
entertainment lawyer and a friend of
Hunter and as you mentioned a democratic
donor that's a lot of money for a canvas
full of Inky spittle but I guess if it's
Hunter spittle maybe it's worth that
kind of cash but I don't see it it's
just like it's kind of like the work the
work he did for that Chinese energy
interest it's sham it's sham work and
this is sham work all right also I mean
this isn't exactly John Singer Sergeant
I mean this is clearly paying for the
influence in the Biden name now people
pay for influence and paintings from uh
famous people all the time but this one
while the president's in office it looks
really bad um but last go ahead what
happened we covered the Biden's dis dis
desperate dis appearance at that black
church in South Carolina he's polling
abysmal with black voters now he's lost
Charlamagne the god Oo we all can get
burned you know by politicians when my
listeners feel like he didn't deliver
they come back to me and they say hey
man you're the one who told us to vote
for uh you know Joe Biden you're the one
who told us to vote for KLA Harris
President Biden historically has been a
a lack of lack of a better word elected
official M Laura the black community is
running from Biden faster than they ran
from Mitt Romney okay 25% drop in
support from the last election to the
most recent polls and you know why
substance matters in the black community
when crime is going up inflation is
eating them and migrants are moving into
their neighborhood and taking those
those uh City funds people notice that's
what this is about Laura I have a Fox
News Alert and I'm glad you're sitting
down for this one I'm so sorry to report
after Seasons as head coach at the
University of Alabama Nick s is Calling
it Quits well I'm doing it for you now
and I'm doing it because it's really I
want to make sure you're okay did this
at the beginning of the show well first
of all I got the news that I'm in the
car coming to the studio and I was
already just shocking shocking to
everybody I was a little late okay
horrible traffic and then I see these
messages coming up one after the other
after the other and the thing that I
realize is my friend David Upton said to
me this morning that he saw Sabin
somewhere or some and that he was in a
great mood and you know he's not one to
sort of he's well sometimes he doesn't
smile a lot right and they they lost the
uh the game against Michigan so you
think maybe he's kind of but he's just
enjoying you know time with his family
and and he has a great wife who's
fantastic she smiles a lot and he's just
happy but he's a great one of the
greatest coaches of all time I mean he
matched he matched be Bryant in national
championships for Alabama and of course
the one with LSU he's the winningest
coach in college football he deserved
his retirement didn't God bless him 297
wins Raymond pretty incredible four
Heisman Trophy winners 10 SEC
championships I was what at the last SEC
Championship and seven uh seven national
titles Nick Sabin one of the greats I
agree hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis say you
will not get it anywhere
else